Last year in Janesville, Wisconsin, the city council had to vote in giving some federal money to the Salvation Army to build a homeless shelter. It's a small town, small enough that the council people are volunteers. And one of them, Paul Williams, voted yes to the federal money, but he added wording saying that the Salvation Army couldn't use the facility to hold prayer services or proselytize because of the separation of church and state. Well, these days, those are fighting words.
去年在威斯康星州简斯维尔，市议会不得不投票决定是否拨出一笔联邦资金给救世军用于建造一家收容所。那是个小镇，小到连议员都是志愿者。其中一位议员保罗·威廉姆斯（Paul Williams）投票赞成这笔联邦拨款，但他增加了一条措辞，称出于政教分离的原则，救世军不得利用该设施进行祈祷仪式或传教。好吧，如今这些话可是会引发争执的。
A couple of congressmen were called, and they got a hold of Secretary Green--
有人给几位国会议员打了电话，他们联系上了格林部长——
This is the secretary of the Department of Housing and Urban Development?
这是住房和城市发展部的部长吗？
Correct.
没错。
So it got up to the United States Cabinet.
所以这件事一直闹到了美国内阁。
Yeah.
是的。
OK. And Janesville is a town of how big?
好的。那简斯维尔有多大？
Janesville is 60,000 people.
简斯维尔有6万人口。
You get a lot of attention from the US Cabinet over there?
你们那儿的事能引起美国内阁的极大关注吗？
No. Not usually.
不，通常不会。
It got bigger. On March 1, President Bush himself chastised the city council, saying that they had, quote, "No right to tell the Salvation Army that the price of running a center was giving up its prayers." In other words, yes, it is illegal to use federal money to proselytize. But just as long as the government was only funding the building and not the prayer service itself, it was fine with the president.
事情闹大了。3月1日，布什总统亲自斥责了市议会，称他们“无权告诉救世军，运营中心的代价就是放弃祈祷”。换句话说，是的，用联邦资金传教确实违法。但只要政府资助的是建筑本身，而不是祈祷仪式，总统就觉得没问题。
For a city councilman who usually deals with sidewalks and zoning questions, who thought he was just following the law, this whole noisy mess was a bit surprising. The local head of the Salvation Army, Major David Taube, was even quoted in The Janesville Gazette, questioning Paul Williams' morality.
对于一位通常只处理人行道和分区规划问题的市议员来说，他本以为自己只是在依法办事，却没想到引发了如此喧嚣的麻烦。救世军当地负责人大卫·陶布（David Taube）少校甚至在《简斯维尔公报》上公开质疑保罗·威廉姆斯的道德水准。
A quote in the newspaper from him said, I have some concerns that we would have a city council person so anti-Christian, so anti-spiritual. I don't know. I'm at a loss for words.
报纸上引述他的话说：我担心我们竟会有这样一位反基督教、反灵性的市议员。我不知道该说什么，我无言以对。
Yeah. And just to be clear, for the record, do you oppose the Christian church?
是的，为了记录在案，我想明确一下，你反对基督教教会吗？
One second on that, OK?
等等，好吗？
Yeah.
好的。
He wants to know, for the record, if I oppose the Christian church.
他想知道，为了记录在案，我是否反对基督教教会。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Um--
呃——
Who were you just saying that to?
你刚才是在对谁说那话？
That's my wife.
那是我妻子。
You just put your hand over the phone, and you said, he wants to know, for the record, if I oppose the Christian church.
你刚才捂住电话话筒说，他想知道，为了记录在案，我是否反对基督教教会。
Yeah. Well, as far as in my political role, again, I try and keep that separate. But no, I do not oppose the Christian church.
是的。嗯，就我的政治角色而言，我还是尽量保持中立。但我不反对基督教教会。
Have you ever celebrated Christmas, the holiday of the Christian church?
你庆祝过圣诞节这个基督教节日吗？
Let's put it this way. I was educated at a Catholic church, married in a Lutheran church, baptized in a Wesleyan church. So yes, I consider myself a Christian.
这么说吧。我在教会学校接受教育，在路德教会结婚，在卫斯理公会受洗。所以是的，我自认为是基督徒。
Thanks to pressure from the Feds, Paul Williams lost. There will be prayer services in the federally funded building. Though in an ironically tidy little ending to the story, the man who called him anti-Christian and anti-spiritual, Major David Taube of the Salvation Army, was recently caught emailing a pornographic picture of himself to somebody who claimed to be a 14-year-old boy. But it was, in fact, a Florida police detective.
在联邦政府的压力下，保罗·威廉姆斯输了。那个联邦资助的建筑里将会有祈祷仪式。不过，故事的结局颇具讽刺意味：那位指责他反基督教、反灵性的大卫·陶布少校，最近被发现向一个自称是14岁男孩的人发送自己的色情照片，但对方其实是一名佛罗里达州的警探。
You know, I don't even know if I should be bringing that up. But once people start calling each other anti-Christian, once it's all about your personal morality, it's hard not to. This is why the Founding Fathers specify in the Constitution that you don't have to have a particular religion to serve in public office. They knew that it just gets ugly when you start dragging everybody's faith into these public debates, and unnecessary.
你知道，我甚至不知道该不该提这件事。但一旦人们开始互相指责反基督教，一旦事情变成关于个人道德的攻击，就很难不提了。这就是为什么开国元勋们在宪法中明确规定，担任公职无需特定的宗教信仰。他们知道，当你们开始把每个人的信仰拖入这些公共辩论时，事情只会变得丑陋且毫无必要。
And it's happening a lot. In Georgia, a science teacher who won the Presidential Award for Excellence in science education, whose taught for 28 years-- and we're asked that we not use her name-- tells this story. Under Georgia state guidelines, she is required to teach evolution, and she's not allowed to teach creationism. So she did what the rule said, and some parents complained. And then a fellow teacher ratted her out, informed the school's administration that evolution was being taught within their walls. Because although the rules say that they're supposed to teach evolution, that doesn't necessarily mean the school followed the rules.
这种情况发生得很多。在佐治亚州，一位曾获得总统科学教育卓越奖、任教28年的科学老师（我们应要求不公开她的姓名）讲述了这样一个故事。根据佐治亚州的指导方针，她被要求教授进化论，且不允许教授神创论。所以她按规定做了，但有些家长提出了投诉。接着，一位同事告发了她，通知学校管理层说校内正在教授进化论。因为尽管规定要求他们教授进化论，但这并不意味着学校真的会遵守规定。
Before Christmas, I was called into the principal's office. And the question was, are you teaching evolution as a fact? And of course, I'm saying yes.
圣诞节前，我被叫到校长办公室。问题是，你是否把进化论作为事实来教？我当然回答是。
Right. Because in a way, you're in a very cut and dry situation. There are state standards. You're supposed to teach them. And you're just teaching them.
对。因为在某种程度上，这是一个非常明确的情况。有州标准，你被要求教授这些，而你只是照章办事。
Well, you'd think that would be cut and dry, wouldn't you?
嗯，你以为这会很明确，对吧？
Over the next few months, she was called into the principal's office two more times. At one meeting, the school superintendent was there to tell her that he didn't believe in evolution and that back when he taught biology, he taught evolution and creationism side by side. She told him that now, that was actually illegal.
在接下来的几个月里，她又被叫到校长办公室两次。在一次会议上，学区总监也在场，他告诉她他不相信进化论，而且当年他教生物学时，是把进化论和神创论并排教的。她告诉他，现在这其实是违法的。
Things got even more strange for her when she was called in for a meeting with her incoming principal about evolution.
当她因进化论问题被叫去与新任校长开会时，情况变得更加离奇了。
We sat down, closed the door. And we got into a discussion of, he wanted me to know where he was coming from. And so he reached around off of his bookshelf and pulled a Bible off his bookshelf. And he said, I believe everything in this Bible. Do you believe everything in this Bible?
我们坐下，关上门。我们开始讨论，他想让我知道他的立场。于是他从书架上拿下一本圣经。他说，我相信这本圣经里的一切。你相信这本圣经里的一切吗？
And he would not let it go. He just wouldn't let it drop. He says, I believe in every single thing in this Bible. And do you believe in everything in this Bible? And I said, yes, I do, but that's not the issue. That was the first time.
他就是不肯罢休。他一直纠缠不放。他说，我相信这本圣经里的每一件事。你相信这本圣经里的一切吗？我说，是的，我相信，但这根本不是重点。那是第一次。
That was the first time? There was more than one time?
那是第一次？还有不止一次？
Yeah. The next time, we were in the cafeteria. And he said, I can accept a lot of things about evolution. But if the scientists ever get to the point where they say God's not involved, I can't accept that. I want you to say that.
是的。下一次是在食堂。他说，关于进化论，我可以接受很多东西。但如果科学家们达到那种声称上帝没有参与的地步，我就无法接受。我要你说出来。
I said, this just doesn't feel right. You shouldn't be asking me these kinds of questions. He said, no. It's just the two of us here. It's like we're just two people talking. If they ever get to the point where the scientists say that God's not involved, I can't accept that. I want you to say that. He wanted me to repeat it after him.
我说，这感觉不对劲。你不应该问我这些问题。他说，不，这里只有我们两个人。就像我们只是两个人聊天一样。如果他们达到那种声称上帝没有参与的地步，我就无法接受。我要你说出来。他要我跟着他重复一遍。
It felt like I was forced to take an oath. It felt like I was forced to declare my religion.
感觉就像我被迫宣誓。感觉就像我被迫宣布我的宗教信仰。
Did you ever think of, like, what year is this that I'm having to fight this?
你有没有想过，这到底是什么年代了，我竟然还要为此抗争？
I know, I know. And it felt like I was a caged animal. Much like I was cornered.
我知道，我知道。感觉就像我是一只困兽。就像我被逼到了墙角。
Lots of teachers don't want this kind of trouble. And people in science education say that in schools all over the country, evolution is mandated, but not being taught. Just as abortion is legal, but hard to find in many places.
很多老师不想惹这种麻烦。科学教育界的人士说，在全国各地的学校里，虽然强制要求教授进化论，但实际上并没有被教授。正如堕胎虽然合法，但在许多地方却很难获得服务。
What's happening in this school-- what's happening all over the place actually-- is not really a debate. It's people acting from two totally different assumptions. One group thinking that religion has no place in public life, the other thinking that, of course, it does. In fact, it needs to be there more.
这所学校发生的事情——其实到处都在发生的事情——并不是真正的辩论。这是两群人基于完全不同的假设在行事。一群人认为宗教在公共生活中没有立足之地，另一群人则认为，当然有，事实上它需要更多地存在。
And people who want the separation of church and state these days-- people who thought these issues were settled-- are finding they're anything but. Christian activists are fighting for friendly judges to be appointed to the bench so that they can get court decisions to swing their way on school prayer, and sex ed, and the Bible in school, and Roe versus Wade.
而那些如今想要政教分离的人——那些以为这些问题已经解决的人——发现事实完全不是这样。基督徒活动家们正在争取任命友好的法官进入司法系统，以便在学校祈祷、性教育、圣经教育和罗诉韦德案等问题上让法院裁决朝着有利于他们的方向发展。
The president has come out and said that he will not appoint judges who don't think that our rights come to us from God. He said this even though the Constitution explicitly forbids a religious test to hold a public office like a judgeship. That's Article Six. You can check that yourself.
总统已经公开表示，他不会任命那些不认为我们的权利来自上帝的法官。他甚至在宪法明确禁止担任公职（如法官）必须经过宗教审查的情况下也这样说。那是第六条。你可以自己去查查。
In April, House Majority Leader Tom DeLay said that the judiciary has imposed, quote, "a separation of church and state that's nowhere in the Constitution."
四月份，众议院多数党领袖汤姆·迪莱（Tom DeLay）称，司法机构强加了一种“宪法中根本没有的政教分离”。
I read that quote. And when I first read it, I had this reaction I think a lot of people might have, which is, isn't the separation of church and state in there somewhere? Isn't that actually one of the ideas that our country is founded on?
我读到了那句话。当我第一次读到时，我想很多人的反应可能和我一样，那就是，政教分离难道不是就在那儿吗？这难道不是我们国家建立的理念之一吗？
Chances are that you are like me, and you haven't actually read the Constitution since high school. So today, to clarify this, we have answers. Is there supposed to be a separation of church and state in our country? And if so, why do so many Americans think otherwise?
你很可能像我一样，自从高中之后就没读过宪法了。所以今天，为了澄清这一点，我们有了答案。我们的国家应该实行政教分离吗？如果应该，为什么那么多美国人认为事实并非如此？
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today, Godless America. Act One of our show, a quick summary of the advances that fundamentalist Christians are making in turning their values into national policy. Act Two, why they believe the founders didn't intend a separation of church and state in the Constitution as we normally understand it, and why. Well, they're probably wrong about that. Act Three, in this very Christian country, in this very Christian moment in our history, Julia Sweeney takes on the Bible. Stay with us.
来自WBEZ芝加哥电台，这里是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目主题是“无神论的美国”。第一幕，简要总结了原教旨主义基督徒在将他们的价值观转化为国家政策方面取得的进展。第二幕，为什么他们认为开国元勋们在宪法中并没有像我们通常理解的那样打算实行政教分离，以及原因是什么。嗯，他们对此可能是错的。第三幕，在这个非常基督教的国家，在这个我们历史上非常基督教的时刻，朱莉娅·斯威尼（Julia Sweeney）要对圣经提出质疑。请继续收听。
Act One, The Substance of Things Hoped For In Government.
第一幕：政府中被期盼事物的本质。
OK. So you've heard about the stem cell fight already, and you've heard about the filibuster fight, which was really about judicial appointments. And you've heard about how gay marriage was outlawed in 13 states in 2004. And you've heard about the pending decisions on evolution in schools in Kansas and Dover, Pennsylvania. But there's a lot more going on than that.
好的。你们已经听过关于干细胞的争论，也听过关于阻挠议事的争论，那实际上是关于司法任命的。你们也听说过2004年有13个州禁止同性婚姻。你们还听说过堪萨斯州和宾夕法尼亚州多佛市关于学校进化论教育的悬而未决的裁决。但发生的事情远不止这些。
First stop on our tour of Christian activists trying to push the country toward more Biblical values, Virginia, where a former state trooper turned legislator named Bill Carrico introduced an amendment to the Virginia Constitution to, quote, "secure further the people's right to acknowledge God," to permit prayer, and the recognition of, quote, "religious beliefs, heritage, and traditions on public property, including public schools."
我们巡视基督徒活动家推动国家向更多圣经价值观靠拢的第一站是弗吉尼亚州，那里的一位前州警、现任立法者比尔·卡里科（Bill Carrico）提出了一项修正案，旨在“进一步保障人民承认上帝的权利”，允许在公共财产（包括公立学校）进行祈祷以及承认“宗教信仰、传统和遗产”。
Now, of course, it's already legal for a child to pray in a public school, or to read a Bible, or to acknowledge their faith. The Supreme Court saw to that years ago. But Bill Carrico says that people do not understand these rights. And so a lot of these cases actually end up in court, which is why, he says, they should amend the state constitution to make the rules perfectly clear.
当然，孩子在公立学校祈祷、阅读圣经或承认自己的信仰本来就是合法的。最高法院多年前就确保了这一点。但比尔·卡里科说，人们并不了解这些权利。所以很多这类案件最终闹上了法庭，这就是为什么他说他们应该修订州宪法，让规则变得一清二楚。
Basically, it was to protect those Christians from being persecuted the way they're being persecuted today just because they are the majority faith.
基本上，这是为了保护那些基督徒免受迫害，因为他们仅仅因为是多数派信仰而受到迫害。
He got interested in the issue when, as a state trooper talking to a high school class before the prom, he mentioned David and Goliath. And parents complained. He says this happens all the time.
他对比这个问题产生兴趣是在他担任州警时，在舞会前向一个高中班级讲话提到了大卫和歌利亚的故事。家长们抱怨了。他说这种情况一直都在发生。
I've got a situation that occurred in Isle of Wight county, where a young girl was looking forward to her high school graduation and having the opportunity to sing. But when she chose the song that she wanted to sing at her graduation, just because it had the mere reference to God in the song, she was removed from the program.
在怀特岛郡发生过这样一件事，一个年轻女孩期待着高中毕业并有机会唱歌。但当她选择了在毕业典礼上演唱的歌曲时，仅仅因为歌词里提到了上帝，她就被从节目单中除名了。
Do you happen to know what song it was?
你知道那是什么歌吗？
It was a Celine Dion song, "The Prayer." And the school officials said, you're crossing the line between separation of church and state, and you're not going to sing that song.
是席琳·迪翁的《祈祷》（The Prayer）。学校官员说，你越界了政教分离的底线，你不能唱那首歌。
Yeah.  So there's a kind of political correctness.
是啊。所以有一种政治正确。
Yes.
是的。
You feel embattled.
你感到备受围攻。
Yes. And you see, this country was founded upon those beliefs. Our laws are written after Biblical laws. And also, the wall of separation of church and state is nowhere in the Constitution. And all it's done is give the secular world, who doesn't profess to believe in anything, the right to say, just because I don't want to hear it, you can't say it.
是的。你看，这个国家就是建立在这些信仰之上的。我们的法律是根据圣经法律编写的。而且，那堵政教分离的墙在宪法中根本不存在。它所做的一切只是给了那些不宣称相信任何东西的世俗世界一个权利，说“仅仅因为我不想听，你就不能说”。
Next up on our tour, Ohio. Pastor Russell Johnson of the Fairfield Christian Church runs something called the Ohio Restoration Project, which wants to sign up 2,000 fundamentalist Baptist and Catholic "patriot pastors" in Ohio's 88 counties, register hundreds of thousands of Christian voters, take control of local Republican groups, and elect a conservative Republican named Kenneth Blackwell to the governor's office in 2006. Pastor Johnson says he's doing pretty well for his goals. 600 pastors signed up so far. He expects to be at 1,000 by Labor Day. He says he is simply restoring Ohio to the Founding Fathers' original Christian values.
我们巡视的下一站是俄亥俄州。费尔菲尔德基督教会的拉塞尔·约翰逊牧师运行着一个名为“俄亥俄州复兴计划”的项目，该计划希望在俄亥俄州的88个县招募2000名原教旨主义浸信会和天主教的“爱国牧师”，注册数十万名基督徒选民，控制当地的共和党组织，并在2006年选举一位保守派共和党人肯尼斯·布莱克威尔（Kenneth Blackwell）担任州长。约翰逊牧师说他的目标实现得不错。目前已有600名牧师加入。他预计到劳动节会达到1000名。他说他只是在让俄亥俄州回归到开国元勋最初的基督教价值观。
And yes, they came here to advance the Christian faith. The sense of separation of church from the state has been a secular jihad that has taken place primarily from the courts. I think, for instance, the discrimination against Christians defies explanation.
是的，他们来这里是为了推进基督教信仰。政教分离的意识形态是一场世俗圣战，主要是由法院推动的。我认为，例如，针对基督徒的歧视简直无法解释。
But still, 84% of Americans identify themselves as Christian. 6 out of 10 Americans say religion is very important in their lives. Only 16% of Americans say religion isn't important. Christians have Christmas off. It's sanctioned by the state. There's no mail service on Sunday. Attendance at evangelical churches is going up. Like--
但即便如此，84%的美国人认为自己是基督徒。十分之六的美国人说宗教在他们的生活中非常重要。只有16%的美国人说宗教不重要。基督徒有圣诞节假期，这是国家批准的。周日没有邮政服务。福音派教堂的出席率正在上升。就像——
Now, I appreciate you did a good thing right there, Ira.
艾拉，我很欣赏你刚才做了一件好事。
I guess I don't-- where is the persecution of Christians?
我不知道——对基督徒的迫害在哪里？
Let me give you a track record on this if I might. From our standpoint, OK? All right. 1962, after 175 years of praying in the classroom, prayer is declared to be somehow an offense. 1963, don't read the Bible. You go on to where they take the Ten Commandments off the walls in Kentucky in '80. In fact, Roe v. Wade.
如果可以的话，让我给你列个记录。从我们的立场来看，好吗？好吧。1962年，在教室里祈祷了175年后，祈祷被宣布为某种冒犯。1963年，不准读圣经。再到1980年肯塔基州把十诫从墙上撤下来。事实上，还有罗诉韦德案。
So we now have these consistent messages from the courts. Never happens at the legislative-- never happens at the level of where people will get a vote. And I think that finally, the Christian community has been pushed to the threshold and said, enough is enough.
所以我们现在从法院得到了这些一致的信息。立法层面从未发生过这种情况——投票选出代表的层面从未发生过这种情况。我认为，基督教社区终于被推到了临界点，并说：够了，受够了。
Do you believe that we can be a moral nation without being Christian?
你相信我们可以在不成为基督教国家的情况下成为一个有道德的民族吗？
Long-term morality without God is a myth.
没有上帝的长期道德是一个神话。
And so if there's a person who believes any of the things that you don't believe-- who believes that a woman should have a right to an abortion, or who believes that gay men and gay women should be allowed to marry-- do you think that the reason that shouldn't be the law in the United States is because we're supposed to be a Christian nation?
所以，如果有一个人相信任何你不相信的东西——比如相信女性应该有堕胎权，或者相信同性恋者应该被允许结婚——你认为这不应该成为美国法律的原因，是因为我们应该是一个基督教国家吗？
No, I candidly-- I don't have a problem with people disagreeing. What I have a problem with is when I have a minority trying to dictate to the supermajority. In an idea, for instance, like because there's one child in the school that doesn't want us to read the Gospels, the life of Christ. One child should not keep the rest of the school from having the privilege of discovering a rich history that we have.
不，坦率地说——我不介意人们有异议。我介意的是少数派试图对超级多数派发号施令。比如，仅仅因为学校里有一个孩子不想让我们读福音书、读基督的生平，这个孩子就不应该阻止其他学校的学生享有发现我们丰富历史的特权。
This is something you hear a lot from Christian activists. They are the majority. And they're turning out their voters. Why shouldn't they get their way? That's what democracy is all about. If most Americans think that it would be OK to have school prayer or teach creationism alongside evolution, well, that's our system in this country.
这是你从基督徒活动家那里经常听到的。他们是多数派。他们正在动员选民。为什么他们不能按自己的方式行事？这就是民主的全部意义。如果大多数美国人认为在学校里进行祈祷或在教授进化论的同时教授神创论是可以接受的，好吧，这就是我们在这个国家的体制。
The 2004 elections emboldened the religious right. They are taking credit for the reelection of President Bush and the increased Republican majority in the Senate and the House. Now they're asking, well, what do we get in return?
2004年的选举鼓舞了宗教右翼。他们将布什总统的连任以及参众两院共和党多数席位的增加归功于自己。现在他们问，好吧，我们能得到什么回报？
This is Rob Boston, a man with a rather unfortunate name to any of us who have watched Survivor . But that's another story. He's been monitoring these sorts of things at Americans United for Separation of Church and State for two decades, and he says that he has never seen Christian conservatives making such headway as they are now.
这是罗伯·波士顿（Rob Boston），对于任何看过《幸存者》的人来说，这是一个相当不幸的名字。但那是另一回事。他在“美国联合政教分离组织”监测这些事情已有二十年了，他说他从未见过像现在这样基督教保守派取得如此巨大的进展。
Some of the bills now before Congress, the House of Worship Free Speech Act, which would make it legal to endorse a candidate from the pulpit and still hold onto your church's tax-exempt status. The Constitution Restoration Act, which would try to bypass the courts on things like the display of the Ten Commandments in public buildings by making it illegal for the courts to rule against any government official or body whose actions acknowledge, quote, "God as the source of life, liberty, or government." There's the Workplace Religious Freedom Act, which counts among its cosponsors Senators John Kerry and Hillary Clinton. This law would force employers to accommodate religious practices and beliefs in the workplace as much as possible.
国会目前的一些法案，比如《礼拜场所言论自由法》，该法案将使在布道坛上支持某位候选人而仍能保持教会免税地位变得合法。《宪法复兴法》，该法案试图在诸如在公共建筑展示十诫等问题上绕过法院，方法是禁止法院对任何动作承认“上帝是生命、自由或政府之源”的政府官员或机构作出裁决。还有《工作场所宗教自由法》，其共同提案人包括参议员约翰·克里和希拉里·克林顿。这项法律将迫使雇主尽可能地在工作场所照顾宗教习俗和信仰。
This, by the way, is coming at a time when a handful of pharmacists around the country have refused to fill birth control prescriptions on moral grounds. And Senator Rick Santorum of Pennsylvania has talked about introducing a federal Conscience Law which would specifically permit that. Four states already have conscience laws like this, Arkansas, Georgia, Mississippi, and South Dakota. Again, Rob Boston.
顺便说一句，这正值全国各地少数药剂师因道德原因拒绝配制避孕处方之际。宾夕法尼亚州的参议员里克·桑托勒姆（Rick Santorum）已经讨论过引入一项联邦《良心法》，专门允许这样做。已有四个州实施了此类良心法，分别是阿肯色州、佐治亚州、密西西比州和南达科他州。还是罗伯·波士顿。
This is an interesting example of where, for many people, these church-state issues seem theoretical. They seem abstract. Whether the Ten Commandments monument is inside the courthouse or outside, whether the Christmas creche is in front of the town green, and who put it up, and how long it's there. And a lot of people would just throw their hands up and say, you know what? I really don't care. But when you look at an issue like, can a woman get her birth control pills because of someone's religious bias and religious beliefs, that's an entirely different thing.
这是一个有趣的例子，在许多人看来，这些政教问题似乎是理论性的。它们似乎很抽象。十诫纪念碑是在法院内部还是外部，圣诞马槽是在城镇广场前，是谁安置的，待了多久。很多人可能会耸耸肩说：你知道吗？我真的不在乎。但是当你审视像“女性是否因为某人的宗教偏见和宗教信仰而无法获得避孕药”这样的问题时，情况就完全不同了。
Do you think a law like this could pass?
你认为像这样的法律能通过吗？
Given the current state of Congress and the heavy influence of the religious right, I think some of these measures that seem really extreme and really out there do have a chance of passing. And then, of course, we're left with the courts to try to overturn them, and the courts are becoming more conservative by the day as well.
考虑到国会目前的状况和宗教右翼的巨大影响力，我认为其中一些看起来非常极端、非常出格的措施确实有可能通过。然后，当然，我们只能指望法院来推翻它们，而法院也正变得越来越保守。
At the heart of everything for the Christian activists, as you've probably gathered, is this idea that America has gotten away from what it was supposed to be. That religious values are supposed to be at the center of everything in our country. And now there's a cottage industry of books and DVDs and other materials telling a history of our country this way.
正如你可能已经了解到的，对于基督徒活动家来说，一切的核心就是这样一种观点：美国已经偏离了它本应成为的样子。宗教价值观本应是我们国家一切事务的中心。现在，出现了一个书籍、DVD和其他材料的家庭作坊产业，以这种方式讲述我们国家的历史。
What was the foundation upon which our Founding Fathers established this great nation? According to John Adams, the foundation was Christianity.
开国元勋们建立这个伟大国家的基石是什么？根据约翰·亚当斯的说法，基石是基督教。
This is from a CD put out by Wallbuilders, which does a lot of this stuff. Wallbuilders.com, by the way. The narrator is David Barton, the founder of Wallbuilders, who declined our request for an interview, but who lays out his case in the materials that he sells.
这是来自Wallbuilders公司发行的CD，他们做了很多这类东西。顺便说一句，网址是Wallbuilders.com。讲述者是大卫·巴顿（David Barton），Wallbuilders的创始人，他拒绝了我们的采访请求，但他所销售的材料中阐述了他的观点。
The evidence that our founders did not want a separation of church and state, in Barton's materials, and whenever everybody else seems to talk about it, comes down to this. The founders were believers who often talked about the importance of God and morality in public life.
在巴顿的材料中，以及每当其他人谈论这个问题时，关于开国元勋不希望政教分离的证据都归结为：开国元勋们是信徒，他们经常谈论上帝和道德在公共生活中的重要性。
And Barton and others point out that the phrase "separation of church and state" is not actually in the Constitution. It comes from a letter that Thomas Jefferson wrote in 1802, which is true.
巴顿等人指出，“政教分离”一词实际上并不在宪法中。它来自托马斯·杰斐逊1802年写的一封信，这是事实。
And then it just comes down to the language of the First Amendment. That's the amendment dealing with religion. Here's David Barton.
然后这最终归结为第一修正案的措辞。那是处理宗教的修正案。这是大卫·巴顿。
Although the phrase "separation of church and state" is well known and commonly associated with the First Amendment, the words "separation," "church," or "state," are not only not found in the First Amendment, they're found in no founding document. Still, many, after learning the phrase is not present, they frequently ask, well, even though the words aren't there, isn't that what the First Amendment really means?
尽管“政教分离”一词众所周知，并通常与第一修正案联系在一起，但“分离”、“教会”或“国家”这些词不仅在第一修正案中找不到，在任何建国文件中也找不到。即便如此，许多人在得知这个词并不存在后，经常会问：好吧，虽然话不在那儿，但那难道不是第一修正案真正的含义吗？
Well, according to the Founding Fathers and their discussions of the First Amendment, which are recorded in the Congressional Records, all they wanted to preclude was what they had experienced in Great Britain. They did not want the establishment by the federal government of one single denomination in exclusion of all others, whether that would be Catholic or Anglican or any other denomination.
好吧，根据开国元勋们及其对第一修正案的讨论（记录在国会记录中），他们想排除的只是他们在英国所经历的一切。他们不希望联邦政府建立一个单一的教派来排斥所有其他教派，无论是天主教、英国国教还是任何其他教派。
Some of these claims I have to be sympathetic with.
对于其中一些说法，我必须表示同情。
We meet one of David Barton's biggest opponents when it comes to history, Isaac Kramnick, a professor at Cornell who co-wrote a well-known constitutional history called The Godless Constitution with R. Laurence Moore.
关于历史，我们见到了大卫·巴顿最大的对手之一：艾萨克·克兰尼克（Isaac Kramnick），康奈尔大学教授，他与R.劳伦斯·摩尔合著了一本著名的宪法史著作《无神论宪法》（The Godless Constitution）。
And here is the first surprise about Kramnick. He agrees with Christian activists that there is far too much political correctness about church and state issues. He thinks people get hung up on this stuff too much of the time, that, of course, a kid should be allowed to sing a Celine Dion song mentioning God at a high school graduation. And Professor Kramnick says that Barton's right on other scores too.
这是关于克兰尼克的第一个令人惊讶之处。他同意基督徒活动家的观点，即在政教问题上存在过多的政治正确。他认为人们太纠结于这些东西了，当然，一个孩子在毕业典礼上演唱提到上帝的席琳·迪翁的歌是应该被允许的。克兰尼克教授说，巴顿在其他方面也是对的。
Barton is correct in that most of the founders were believers. Many liberals get very upset when people like David Barton put out a list of all the quotes from the Founding Fathers about God, because they would like to sort of sweep them away. That the Founding Fathers, Jefferson included, never really spoke about God, and that God was unimportant to them. That's not right. It makes it all the more profound that these people were indeed, many of them, believers. They had no problem with a religious nation, a religious people. But they wanted a secular government.
巴顿说得对，大多数开国元勋都是信徒。当像大卫·巴顿这样的人列出开国元勋关于上帝的所有语录时，许多自由派感到非常不安，因为他们想把这些语录扫地出门。他们认为开国元勋（包括杰斐逊）从未真正谈论过上帝，上帝对他们来说并不重要。那是不对的。这使得这些人确实——他们中的许多人——是信徒这一点显得更加深刻。他们对宗教国家、宗教人民没有任何意见。但他们想要一个世俗政府。
And this, of course, was a great break from the past. And that, in fact, is the incredible achievement of America.
当然，这与过去有着巨大的决裂。事实上，这正是美国了不起的成就。
Kramnick says the founders wanted to keep religion out of government completely because they knew what happened in 16th century Europe, when millions of Protestants and Catholics killed each other in religious wars. In the wake of that, the philosopher John Locke theorized about a kind of government that could be completely secular. Take no sides in religion at all. And there's lots of documentation showing that Locke and his vision of government had a huge influence on the drafters of the Constitution.
克兰尼克说，开国元勋们想要完全将宗教排除在政府之外，因为他们知道16世纪欧洲发生了什么，当时数以百万计的新教徒和天主教徒在宗教战争中互相残杀。在此之后，哲学家约翰·洛克提出了某种可以完全世俗化的政府理论。在宗教上不偏袒任何一方。而且有很多文献表明，洛克及其政府愿景对宪法起草者产生了巨大的影响。
And sure, says Kramnick. Barton's right again. The Constitution never explicitly says the phrase "separation of church and state."
当然，克兰尼克说，巴顿又说对了。宪法从未明确使用“政教分离”这个短语。
That's true. So the argument about it not being in the Constitution is absolutely correct. It's not in the Constitution. Nor, of course, is God, or religion, or Protestantism, or the furthering of any faith in the Constitution either.
这是真的。所以关于它不在宪法中的争论是绝对正确的。它不在宪法中。当然，上帝、宗教、新教或任何信仰的推进也不在宪法中。
As you write in your book, they mention a creator in the Declaration of Independence, they mention a creator in the Articles of Confederation. In many state constitutions, they mention a creator. But here, they consciously do not mention a creator at all.
正如你在书中写的，他们在《独立宣言》中提到了造物主，在《邦联条例》中提到了造物主。在许多州宪法中，他们提到了造物主。但在这里，他们有意识地完全没有提到造物主。
Absolutely. And then, to add insult to injury, Article Six of the Constitution says, there shall be no religious test for public office. And that created a firestorm around the country.
绝对如此。然后，为了雪上加霜，宪法第六条规定：担任公职不得有宗教审查。这在全国引起了轩然大波。
Now you should explain what a religious test is. That means--
现在你应该解释一下什么是宗教审查。那意味着——
A religious test was that in 11 of the 13 states, in their constitutions, in 1787, said you could only hold public office if you were Protestant. What happened after September 1787 in Philadelphia with the signing of the Constitution was that it wouldn't go into effect until 9 of the 13 states ratified it.
宗教审查是指在1787年，13个州中有11个州的宪法规定你只有是新教徒才能担任公职。1787年9月费城签署宪法后，发生的事情是，它必须得到13个州中9个州的批准才能生效。
Americans have no idea how close the Constitution came to being not ratified. How in these state ratifying conventions, the vote would be 30 to 27, something of that sort. And one of the lightning rod areas of debate was, in fact, about religion, was the omission of any religious purpose from the Constitution. No reference to God, no reference to Christ.
美国人根本不知道宪法差点就没被批准。在这些州批准会议上，投票结果往往是30比27之类的。辩论的焦点之一，实际上就是关于宗教，就是宪法中遗漏了任何宗教目的。没有提及上帝，没有提及基督。
Now, in each of these state conventions, for the next year, there was a huge cry that the Constitution be changed to eliminate the no religious test clause. With claims like it'll allow a Papist, a Mohammedan, an infidel, a Jew to hold public office. The proponents of the Constitution said no. And in fact, each effort in each of the states was turned down, which was read at the time as a clear announcement that government is a secular function and has no religious purpose. And this is how we know that despite the fact that there's nothing in the Constitution about formally saying separation of church and state, we know what their attitudes were to religion and government.
现在，在接下来的这一年里，在每一个州的会议上，都有巨大的呼声要求修改宪法以取消“无宗教审查”条款。声称这会让教皇信徒、穆罕默德信徒、异教徒、犹太人担任公职。宪法支持者说不。事实上，每个州提出的每一项努力都被否决了，这在当时被解读为一种明确的公告，即政府是世俗职能，没有宗教目的。这就是我们知道尽管宪法中没有明确写出政教分离的字眼，但我们依然知道他们对宗教和政府态度的原因。
Then there were a series of fights over the separation of church and state, including a 20-year battle starting in the early 19th century over whether US post offices should be closed on Sundays so that work wouldn't happen on the Christian Sabbath. Ministers gathered names on petitions. They took it to Congress.
然后发生了一系列关于政教分离的争论，包括19世纪初开始的一场持续20年的斗争，争论焦点是美国邮局是否应该在周日关闭，以便不在基督教安息日工作。牧师们在请愿书上收集名字。他们把它提交给国会。
And Congress said no. Congress said no. A staunch Baptist was the head of the committee that recommended to Congress that this would be an unconstitutional interference of Congress in religious matters.
而国会拒绝了。国会拒绝了。一位坚定的浸信会教徒担任了委员会负责人，他建议国会说，这将是国会在宗教事务上的违宪干预。
And then perhaps the most dramatic example occurs during the Civil War, when, as unbelievable as it seems, many Protestant ministers convened conventions to plead to amend the Constitution to put Jesus Christ and Christian government into the preamble to the Constitution.
然后，也许最引人注目的例子发生在内战期间，当时，令人难以置信的是，许多新教牧师召集会议，恳求修改宪法，将耶稣基督和基督教政府写入宪法序言。
And their argument, you write, is basically, the reason why we got into this mess and now we're at war is because when we wrote the Constitution, God wasn't in the Constitution, and now God is basically punishing us for that.
你写道，他们的论点基本上是：我们陷入困境并陷入战争的原因是，当我们编写宪法时，上帝不在宪法里，而现在上帝基本上是在为此惩罚我们。
Absolutely. And therefore, they proposed the Christian amendment which would change the preamble of the Constitution to, "We the people of the United States, humbly acknowledging Almighty God as the source of all authority and power in civil government, the Lord Jesus Christ as the governor among the nations, and his revealed will as a supreme authority, in order to constitute a Christian government, do ordain and establish this Constitution for the United States of America."
绝对如此。因此，他们提议了“基督教修正案”，将宪法序言修改为：“我们合众国人民，谦卑地承认全能的上帝是公民政府一切权力和权威的源泉，主耶稣基督是万国之主，他显明的旨意是至高权威，为了建立一个基督教政府，特此为美利坚合众国颁布并确立本宪法。”
Now, how'd they do with that? You write that they did meet with President Lincoln.
那么，他们进展如何？你写道他们确实见了林肯总统。
They met with President Lincoln, who would have nothing to do with it. There was criticism from a large number of religious groups in the country. And it never got out of committee.
他们见了林肯总统，他根本不理会这件事。国内有大量宗教团体对此表示批评。而且它从未出过委员会。
Now just to put the final footnote to that story, five more times there would be a Christian amendment put before Congress, and every one of them failed. 1874, 1894, 1910, 1947, and 1954. And there was a kind of booby prize given in 1863 when this failed. And that booby prize was, of course, that "In God We Trust" was put on our money. A somewhat less sacred part of our tradition than the Constitution.
为了给那个故事加个最后的脚注，国会又先后五次提交了“基督教修正案”，但每一次都失败了。分别是1874年、1894年、1910年、1947年和1954年。而1863年这次失败时，他们得到了一种安慰奖。那个安慰奖就是“我们信仰上帝”（In God We Trust）被印在了我们的货币上。这部分传统比宪法本身神圣程度要低一些。
But what's fascinating is that Barton and DeLay and Falwell and Ralph Reed have a story. And their story goes like this. The founders set up a Christian government which persisted until the 1960s. And then in the 1960s, a sort of subversive cabal of secularists, liberals, eroded and subverted this government which was supposedly to serve God's purpose.
但引人注目的是，巴顿、迪莱、法尔韦尔和拉尔夫·里德有一个故事。他们的故事是这样的：元勋们建立了一个基督教政府，一直持续到20世纪60年代。然后，在60年代，一个由世俗主义者、自由派组成的颠覆性阴谋集团侵蚀并颠覆了这个本应服务于上帝目的的政府。
In fact, the story, ironically, is just the opposite, which is the Constitution-- 1787 until the 1950s, the David Bartons and the Tom DeLays of the country were angry that the Constitution was secular, calling it a godless Constitution. And then in the 1950s, it's just the opposite. The secular foundation of government is, in fact, eroded because of the Cold War. In the Cold War, America came to define itself as godly people, of course, fighting godless, atheistic Communism.
事实上，讽刺的是，故事恰恰相反，也就是宪法——1787年到20世纪50年代，全国的大卫·巴顿们和汤姆·迪莱们对宪法是世俗的感到愤怒，称其为无神论宪法。然后在20世纪50年代，情况恰恰相反。政府的世俗基石实际上是因为冷战而受到侵蚀。在冷战中，美国开始将自己定义为敬虔的民族，当然，是与无神论的共产主义作斗争。
So it's in the 1950s that you get the first presidential prayer breakfasts. You get the first congressional prayer rooms. And you get Eisenhower saying, we are a nation of believers. And perhaps even more important, the insertion of God into the Pledge of Allegiance.
所以是在20世纪50年代，你才有了第一次总统祈祷早餐会。你有了第一个国会祈祷室。而且你有了艾森豪威尔说，我们是一个信徒的民族。或许更重要的是，在效忠誓词中加入了“上帝”。
Isaac Kramnick, coauthor of the book The Godless Constitution. The book is being reissued in August with a new chapter about the Bush presidency.
艾萨克·克兰尼克，《无神论宪法》一书的合著者。这本书将于八月再版，并增加了一章关于布什总统任期的内容。
Coming up, it's the old story. Girl loves God. Girl reads Bible. Girl's not so sure anymore how she feels about God. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，这是一个老套的故事。女孩爱上帝。女孩读圣经。女孩不再那么确定自己对上帝的感觉了。那是在一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际台的节目，稍后继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Godless America. And we've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, God Said, Huh?
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种不同类型的相关故事。今天的节目，“无神论的美国”。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕：上帝说，哈？
Religious people don't see it this way, but I would argue that God has gotten a lot of play in the mass media lately. There was that saturation coverage of the death of the pope and the picking of the new pope. There are continual attempts by Hollywood these days, in the post-Mel Gibson environment, to do various God-related projects. There's Joan of Arcadia and Seventh Heaven and Revelations and a number of other TV shows.
宗教人士并不这样看，但我认为最近大众媒体对上帝的报道太多了。有关于教皇去世和新教皇选出的饱和报道。在后梅尔·吉布森时代，好莱坞目前不断尝试进行各种与上帝相关的项目。《圣女贞德》、《第七天堂》、《启示录》以及其他一些电视节目。
This story you're about to hear takes a different point of view about God. Julia Sweeney was on Saturday Night Live. She's been in all sorts of movies and TV shows. She also did a one-woman show a couple years back about her struggle with cancer called "God Said, 'Ha!'" which Quentin Tarantino made into a film. Her latest one-woman show, which has been playing in Los Angeles, is about-- well, it's about God. This is an excerpt.
你们即将听到的这个故事对上帝持有一种不同的观点。朱莉娅·斯威尼曾在《周六夜现场》工作。她出演过各种电影和电视节目。几年前，她还做过一个关于她抗癌斗争的单人秀，叫《上帝说，“哈！”》，昆汀·塔伦蒂诺把它拍成了电影。她最新的单人秀一直在洛杉矶演出，是关于——嗯，是关于上帝的。这是一段摘录。
Not too long ago, two Mormon missionaries came to my door. They were each about 19, in white, starched, short-sleeved shirts, and they said they had a message for me from God. And I guess I was sort of curious, so I said, please, come in. And they seemed really happy because I don't think that happens to them all that often. And I sat them down in the living room, and I got them glasses of water. And after our niceties, I said, OK. I'm ready for my message from God.
不久前，两名摩门教传教士来到我家。他们大约19岁，穿着白色、浆过、短袖的衬衫，他们说他们有上帝给我的口信。我想我有点好奇，所以我就说，请进。他们看起来很高兴，因为我不认为这种事常发生在他们身上。我让他们在客厅坐下，给他们倒了水。客套之后，我说，好吧。我准备好听上帝给我的口信了。
But they had a question instead, which really threw me a little. I thought it would be more like a pitch at a studio. And they would tell me their story, and then if I were interested, I would have my people call their people or something. But apparently, this was going to be interactive. And they said, do you believe that God loves you with all his heart?
但他们反而问了一个问题，这真的让我有点困惑。我以为这会更像电影公司的提案。他们会告诉我他们的故事，然后如果我感兴趣，我会让我的团队联系他们的团队什么的。但显然，这将会是互动的。他们说，你相信上帝全心全意地爱你吗？
And I thought, well, of course, I believe in God. But I don't like that word heart because that so anthropomorphizes God. And I don't like the word his either because that sexualizes God. But then I didn't want to argue semantics with these boys. So after a very long, uncomfortable pause, I said, yes. Yes, I do. I feel very loved. And then they looked at each other and smiled, like that was the right answer.
我想，好吧，我当然相信上帝。但我不喜欢“心”这个词，因为它太拟人化上帝了。我也不喜欢“他”这个词，因为它将上帝性别化了。但后来我不想和这些男孩争论语义。所以在一段非常漫长、尴尬的沉默之后，我说，是的。是的，我信。我感觉被深深地爱着。然后他们互相看了看，笑了，好像那是正确答案一样。
And then they said, do you believe that we're all brothers and sisters on this planet? And I immediately said, yes I do, yes, I do. And I was so relieved that it was a question that I could just answer quickly. And they said, well, then we have a story to tell you.
然后他们说，你相信我们在这个星球上都是兄弟姐妹吗？我立刻说，是的，我信，我信。我很庆幸这是一个我可以快速回答的问题。他们说，好吧，那我们有个故事要讲给你听。
And they told me this story all about this guy named Lehi who lived in Jerusalem in 600 BC. Now apparently, in Jerusalem in 600 BC, everyone was completely bad and evil. Every single one of them. Man, woman, child, infant, fetus. And God came to Lehi, and he said, put your family on a boat, and I will lead you out of here.
他们讲了一个关于利哈伊（Lehi）的人的故事，他住在公元前600年的耶路撒冷。显然，在公元前600年的耶路撒冷，每个人都彻底地坏，彻底地邪恶。每一个男人、女人、孩子、婴儿、胎儿。上帝来到利哈伊面前，对他说，把你家带上船，我会带你们离开这里。
And so he did. And God led them to America.
于是他照做了。上帝把他们带到了美国。
I said, America? From Jerusalem to America by boat in 600 BC? And they said, yes. And then they told me how Lehi and his descendants reproduced and reproduced. And eventually, over the course of 600 years, there were two races of them, the Nephites and Lamanites. And the Nephites were totally, totally good, each and every one of them. And the Lamanites were totally bad and evil, every single one of them, just bad to the bone.
我说，美国？公元前600年从耶路撒冷乘船到美国？他们说，是的。然后他们告诉我利哈伊和他的后代是如何繁衍的。最终，在600年的时间里，他们分成了两个种族，尼腓人和拉曼人。尼腓人完全、完全是好的，每一个都是。而拉曼人则完全是坏的、邪恶的，每一个都是，坏到骨子里。
Then after Jesus died on the cross for our sins, on his way up to heaven, he stopped by America and visited the Nephites. And he said that if the Nephites all remained totally good, each and every one of them, they would win this war against the Lamanites. But apparently, somebody blew it, and the Lamanites killed all the Nephites. All except this one guy named Mormon who managed to survive by hiding in the woods. And he made sure that this whole story was written down in reformed Egyptian hieroglyphics chiseled onto gold plates, which he then buried near Palmyra, New York.
后来在耶稣为我们的罪死在十字架上后，他在去天堂的路上，路过美国并探访了尼腓人。他说如果尼腓人保持完全的善良，每一个都保持善良，他们就能赢得那场针对拉曼人的战争。但显然，有人搞砸了，拉曼人杀死了所有的尼腓人。除了一个叫摩尔门（Mormon）的人，他通过躲在树林里幸存了下来。他确保整个故事被记录在刻在金板上的改革后的埃及象形文字中，然后他把金板埋在了纽约州帕尔米拉附近。
And then they told me how this guy named Joseph Smith found the buried gold plates right in his backyard. And he also found this magic stone back there that he put into his hat and then buried his face into it. And this allowed him to translate the gold plates from the reformed Egyptian into English.
然后他们告诉我这个叫约瑟·斯密（Joseph Smith）的人是如何在他的后院发现了被埋的金板。他还发现了那里的一块魔法石，他把它放进帽子里，然后把脸埋进去。这使他能够将金板上的改革后埃及文字翻译成英语。
Well, I was just looking at these boys with wide eyes, and I was really wishing I could give them some advice about their pitch. I wanted to say, OK, don't start with this story. I mean, even the Scientologists know to give a personality test before they start telling you all about Xenu, the evil intergalactic overlord.
好吧，我只是睁大眼睛看着这些男孩，我真的很想给他们一些关于他们的提案建议。我想说，好吧，别从这个故事开始。我的意思是，即使是山达基教徒也知道在告诉你关于邪恶的跨星系霸主泽努（Xenu）之前先做一个性格测试。
Well, then they said, well, we also believe that if you're a Mormon and if you're in good standing with the church, when you die, you get to go to heaven and be with your family for all eternity. And I said, oh, dear. That wouldn't really be such a good incentive for me. I mean, everyone in your family?
好吧，然后他们说，好吧，我们也相信如果你是摩门教徒，如果你在教会中地位良好，当你死后，你就会上天堂，和你的家人永远在一起。我说，哦，天哪。那对我来说真的不是一个很好的激励。我的意思是，你们家庭里的每个人？
And then they gave me a Book of Mormon, and they told me to read this chapter and that chapter. And they said they'd come back someday and check in on me. And I think I said something like, please don't hurry. Or maybe it was just, please don't. And they were gone.
然后他们给了我一本《摩门经》，告诉我去读这一章那一章。他们说他们改天会再回来看看我。我想我说了类似“请别急”的话。或者也许只是“请别来”。然后他们就走了。
OK. So I initially felt pretty superior to these boys and really smug in my more conventional faith. But then the more I thought about it, I had to be honest with myself. I mean, if someone came to my door and I was hearing Catholic theology and dogma for the very first time, and they said, we believe that God impregnated a very young girl without the use of intercourse, and the fact that she was a virgin is maniacally important to us, and she had a baby, and that was the son of God, I would think that was equally ridiculous. I guess I'm just so used to that story. So I couldn't let myself feel condescending towards these boys.
好吧。所以我起初对这些男孩感到相当优越，对我的传统信仰感到沾沾自喜。但后来我想得越多，就越必须对自己诚实。我的意思是，如果有人来到我家，而我是第一次听到天主教的神学和教条，如果他们说，我们相信上帝在没有性交的情况下让一个非常年轻的女孩受孕，而且她是处女这一事实对我们来说极其重要，她生了一个孩子，那就是上帝之子，我会觉得这同样荒谬。我想我只是太习惯那个故事了。所以我无法让自己对这些男孩表现得居高临下。
But the question they asked me when they first arrived stuck in my head. Do you believe that God loves you with all his heart? Because I wasn't exactly sure how I felt about that question. Now, if they had asked me, do you feel that God loves you with all his heart, now, that question would have been much easier. I would have instantly answered yes. Yes, I feel it all the time. I feel God's love when I'm hurt and confused, and I feel consoled and cared for.
但他们刚到时问我的那个问题一直在我脑海里挥之不去。你相信上帝全心全意地爱你吗？因为我不太确定我对那个问题有什么感觉。现在，如果他们问我，你感觉上帝全心全意地爱你吗，那么这个问题就容易多了。我会立刻回答是的。是的，我一直能感觉到。当我受伤和困惑时，我感觉到上帝的爱，我感到被安慰和照顾。
But since they asked me the question with the word "believe" in it, somehow it was all different. Because I wasn't sure if I believed what I so clearly felt.
但既然他们用“相信”这个词问我，不知怎么地，一切都不同了。因为我不确定我是否相信我如此清晰感受到的东西。
OK. My religious history in a nutshell. I was raised Catholic, and for me, it was all in all a great experience. I know we can't stop reading about all of the people who have had just horrific and abusive experiences as a child in the Catholic church. But for me, it was mostly wonderful. I always felt really lucky to be a Catholic. It was easy for me to believe. I even had religious experiences. I know this is more of a Protestant thing than a Catholic thing, but I had a few times, maybe five or six times, where I felt the power of the Holy Spirit, this force of love and transcendence, come over me and just shake me to the core.
好的。简单概括我的宗教历史。我是天主教徒，对我来说，总的来说这是一次伟大的经历。我知道我们无法停止阅读关于所有在天主教会中度过了可怕和虐待性童年的人们的故事。但对我来说，它大部分是美好的。我一直觉得作为一名天主教徒非常幸运。我很容易相信。我甚至有过宗教体验。我知道这更像是新教而非天主教的事情，但我有几次，也许五六次，感到圣灵的力量，这种爱和超越的力量，降临在我身上，震撼了我的灵魂。
And in spite of their nutty story, the Mormon boys inspired me. I realized I'd been getting lazy about my faith. So I decided to rededicate myself to the church.
尽管他们的故事很疯狂，但摩门教男孩启发了我。我意识到我在信仰上变懒了。所以我决定重新投身于教会。
I went to Mass at several different Catholic churches and finally settled on joining one about 10 miles from my house. Their Masses were so emotional. I would have to choke back tears just to say the Nicene Creed every time I went. "We believe in one God, the Father Almighty, creator of heaven and earth, and of all things seen and unseen." Well, I noticed in the announcements that the church offered a Bible study class on Thursday nights, and I decided to sign up for it.
我去了几家不同的天主教堂参加弥撒，最后决定加入离我家10英里远的一家。他们的弥撒太感人了。每次我去的时候，我都不得不强忍泪水来说尼西亚信经。“我们相信唯一的神，全能的父，创造天地万物，及所有可见和不可见之物。”好吧，我注意到公告里说教会每周四晚上提供圣经研习班，我决定报名参加。
The Catholics don't really emphasize the Bible all that much. Their attitude is sort of, leave that book to the professionals. Don't you worry your little self with that complicated book. So I felt eager to finally read this book, this book that I'd always wanted to take the time to read, but I really never had. And I was happy to see that the Old Testament starts out with two conflicting stories about the origin of the universe, one where Adam and Eve are created at the exact same moment, and then in the next chapter, a second creation story where Adam is created first, and then Eve is created out of his rib after he gets lonely.
天主教徒并不怎么强调圣经。他们的态度有点像，把那本书留给专业人士吧。别让那本复杂的书困扰你那小小的脑袋。所以我渴望终于读读这本书，这本书我一直想花时间去读，但我从来没有。我很高兴看到旧约以两个关于宇宙起源的冲突故事开始，一个是亚当和夏娃在同一时刻被创造，然后下一章又是一个第二个创造故事，亚当先被创造，然后在他感到孤独后夏娃从他的肋骨中被创造出来。
And I thought, wow. For all those people who believe every word of the Bible is true, they can't even have read the first two chapters. In fact, the Bible contradicts itself all over the place.
我想，哇。对于所有那些相信圣经中每一个字都是真理的人来说，他们甚至可能没读过前两章。事实上，圣经在很多地方都在自相矛盾。
Then we got to stories like Sodom and Gomorrah. All I remembered about that story is that they were these two sinful cities, like Las Vegas or something, and God got mad and wiped them out. And Lot's wife looked back when she was told not to and got turned into a pillar of salt.
然后我们读到了索多玛和蛾摩拉这样的故事。关于那个故事，我唯一记得的就是它们是两个邪恶的城市，就像拉斯维加斯之类的地方，上帝发怒把它们毁灭了。罗得的妻子在被告知不要回头时回了头，变成了一根盐柱。
But the nuns of my grade school didn't explain to us what happens right before they flee. Right before they flee, two angels that are masquerading as two men come for a visit and stay overnight at Lot's house. And this mob forms outside, and they yell, send out those two angel-like men to us so we can have sex with them. And Lot yells, no, which I think is a basic rule of hospitality. Don't give up your guests to be raped by an angry mob.
但我小学时修女并没有给我们解释在他们逃走前发生了什么。就在他们逃走前，两个伪装成男人的天使来访，在罗得家过夜。屋外聚集了一群暴民，他们喊道：把那两个像天使一样的男人带出来给我们，我们要和他们发生性关系。罗得喊道：不，我认为这是待客的基本原则。不要把你的客人交给愤怒的暴民去强奸。
But then what does he say next? He says, instead of the men, please, take my daughters, and rape, and do what you will with them. They're virgins.
但接下来他说什么？他说，除了男人，请，带走我的女儿们，强奸她们，对她们做你们想做的吧。她们是处女。
After Lot and his traumatized daughters flee Sodom and Gomorrah, they all go to a cave in the mountains. And during the night, Lot's two daughters get him drunk and rape him. Do they do this in revenge of what their father did to them? No. The Bible says it's because there aren't any other men around. Even though the Bible also says that they're not that far from a city named Zoar. So I guess no men around for maybe a few miles? And wait a minute. So Lot's daughters just had to drug and rape someone? And I guess if you're their dad and you're the only one there--
在罗得和他受惊的女儿们逃离索多玛和蛾摩拉后，他们都去了山里的一个洞穴。在夜里，罗得的两个女儿让他喝醉并强奸了他。她们是为了报复她们父亲对她们做的事吗？不。圣经说这是因为周围没有其他男人。尽管圣经也说她们离一个叫琐珥的城市并不远。所以我猜周围几英里内可能没有男人？等等。所以罗得的女儿们只是不得不给某人下药并强奸他？我猜如果你是她们的父亲，而且你是唯一在那里的人——
I knew the Bible had nutty stories, but I guess I thought they'd be wedged in amongst an ocean of inspiration and history. But instead, the stories just got darker and more convoluted. Like when God asks Abraham to murder his son Isaac. As a kid, we were taught to admire it. I caught my breath reading it. We were taught to admire it? What kind of sadistic test of loyalty is that, to ask someone to kill his or her own child? And isn't the proper answer no, I will not kill my child or any child?
我知道圣经里有疯狂的故事，但我以为它们会被夹杂在灵感和历史的海洋中。但相反，这些故事变得越来越黑暗和复杂。就像当上帝要求亚伯拉罕谋杀他的儿子以撒时。作为一个孩子，我们被教导要赞美它。读到这里我屏住了呼吸。我们被教导要赞美它？那是多么变态的忠诚度测试啊，要求某人杀害他或她自己的孩子？难道正确的回答不应该是：不，我不会杀害我的孩子或任何孩子？
At the next class, Father Tom reminded us that Isaac represents what matters to Abraham most, and that's what God asks us to give up for him. I said, but protecting and loving and caring for the welfare of your child is such a deep ethical, loving instinct and act. So what if what matters to you most is your own loving behavior? Should we be willing to give up our ethics for God? And he said, no, it's what matters to you most. It isn't your ethics because your ethics is your love and faith in God. That confused me, but I decided to just let it go.
在下一次课上，汤姆神父提醒我们，以撒代表了亚伯拉罕最看重的东西，而上帝要求我们为他放弃那一切。我说，但保护、爱和关心你孩子的福利是一种深沉的道德和爱的本能与行为。那么，如果你最看重的是你自己的爱心行为呢？我们应该愿意为了上帝放弃我们的道德吗？他说，不，这是你最看重的东西。它不是你的道德，因为你的道德就是你对上帝的爱和信仰。这让我很困惑，但我决定还是顺其自然吧。
But then I found that Abraham wasn't the only person willing to murder his own child for God. They're all over the place in the Bible. For example, in the Book of Judges, a guy named Jephthah tells God that if God helps him win this battle, he will kill the first person to greet him when he comes home. Who turns out to be his daughter. Who he sets on fire.
但我发现亚伯拉罕并不是唯一一个愿意为上帝谋杀自己孩子的人。圣经里到处都是。例如，在《士师记》中，一个叫耶弗他的人告诉上帝，如果上帝帮他赢得这场战斗，他就会杀死第一个回家迎接他的人。结果竟然是他的女儿。他把她烧死了。
Some people argue that without the Bible, morality would be relative and wishy-washy. But in the Bible, morality is relative and wishy-washy. In fact, it sure seems like our modern morality is much more loving and humane than the Bible's morality.
有些人认为如果没有圣经，道德将是相对的和软弱的。但在圣经中，道德确实是相对的和软弱的。事实上，看起来我们现代的道德比圣经的道德更加仁爱和人道。
After Mass one Sunday, Father Tom saw me outside the church, and he said, Julia, you always look so very sad in Bible study class. And I said, well, God is so offensive in the Old Testament. I mean, like, bipolar. And Father Tom said, well, you know, the Old Testament. The stories are legends. They're tales of trickery and deception that were told around the campfire. There's no evidence that Abraham is anything other than legend. Or Isaac, or Moses. But Julia, you can't approach the Bible with modern historical eyes. You've got to read it with the eyes of faith. This is the story that God wants us to know.
一个周日弥撒后，汤姆神父在教堂外看到我，他说：朱莉娅，你在圣经研习班上看起来总是很忧伤。我说：好吧，上帝在旧约里太冒犯人了。我的意思是，就像双相情感障碍。汤姆神父说：好吧，你知道，旧约。这些故事是传说。它们是在营火周围讲述的关于诡计和欺骗的故事。没有证据表明亚伯拉罕不仅仅是传说。或者以撒，或者摩西。但朱莉娅，你不能用现代历史的眼光去看待圣经。你必须用信仰的眼光去读它。这是上帝想让我们知道的故事。
As I drove home, I thought, OK, calm down. This is the Old Testament. Old. Old is right in the title. A new, a newer testament is coming up. And that's why God sent his son Jesus. Because we clearly hadn't gotten the message right. Right? I could hardly wait to meet Jesus again as if it were the first time.
当我在开车回家的路上，我想，好吧，冷静点。这是旧约。旧。旧就在标题里。一本新的，一本更新的约书即将到来。这就是为什么上帝派遣他的儿子耶稣。因为我们显然没有正确理解这个信息。对吗？我简直迫不及待地想再次见到耶稣，就像这是第一次一样。
But oh dear. Well, first off, Jesus is much angrier than I expected him to be. I knew that Jesus got angry with all those money changers in the temple and everything, but I didn't know that he was so angry so much of the time. And very impatient.
但哦，亲爱的。嗯，首先，耶稣比我预期的要愤怒得多。我知道耶稣对神殿里那些兑换银钱的人感到生气等等，但我不知道他大部分时间都那么愤怒。而且非常不耐烦。
For example, Jesus says he teaches in parables because people don't understand anything else. But the parables are often foggy and meaningless, and Jesus is snippy when even the disciples don't get them. He says, if you don't understand this parable, then how can you understand any parable? And, are you incapable of understanding?
例如，耶稣说他用寓言教导，因为人们听不懂别的。但这些寓言往往模糊而毫无意义，而且当连门徒都不懂时，耶稣会很刻薄。他说：如果你不懂这个寓言，那你怎么能懂任何寓言？还有，你们缺乏理解能力吗？
I kept thinking, don't teach in parables then. It's not working. Even your staff doesn't understand them. Why don't you just say what you mean?
我一直想，那别用寓言教导啊。根本行不通。连你的员工都不懂它们。你为什么不直接说出你想表达的意思？
And it was hard to stay on Jesus's side when he started saying really aggressive, hateful things. Like in Luke. Jesus says that he is like a king who says, anyone who does not recognize me, bring them here and slaughter them before me. Or in John chapter 15, where Jesus says that anyone who doesn't believe in him is like a withered branch that will be cast into the fire and burned. In Matthew, he says, I come not to bring peace, but a sword. And then in Luke, he says, and if you don't have a sword, sell your clothes and buy one.
当耶稣开始说非常激进、充满仇恨的话时，很难保持站在他这边。就像在路加福音里。耶稣说他就像一个国王，说：那些不承认我的人，把他们带到这里，在我面前杀掉。或者在约翰福音第15章，耶稣说任何不相信他的人就像枯萎的枝条，会被扔进火里烧掉。在马太福音里，他说：我来不是为了带来和平，而是带来剑。然后路加福音说：如果你没有剑，卖掉你的衣服去买一把。
Then Jesus just starts acting downright crazy. Like in Matthew chapter 21. When a fig tree doesn't have a fig for him to eat, Jesus condemns the fig tree to death. That's right. Jesus condemns a fig tree to death. Not a parable, by the way. Just Jesus, pissed off that the fig tree didn't have a fig for him to eat when he wanted one. Not exactly the Prince of Peace who taught us to turn the other cheek.
然后耶稣就开始表现得彻彻底底疯狂了。就像在马太福音第21章。当一棵无花果树没有果子给他吃时，耶稣判了无花果树死刑。没错。耶稣判了无花果树死刑。顺便说一句，那不是寓言。只是耶稣因为无花果树在他想吃的时候没有果子给他吃而愤怒。这可不是那位教导我们“左脸被打转过右脸”的和平之子。
And then there's family. I have to say the most upsetting thing to me about Jesus is his family values, which is amazing when you think how there's so many groups out there who say they base their family values on the Bible. I mean, he seems to have no real close ties to his parents. He puts Mary off cruelly over and over again. At the wedding feast he says to her, woman, what have I to do with you? And once, while he was speaking to this crowd, Mary waited patiently off to the side to talk to him. And Jesus said to the disciples, send her away, you are my family now.
然后是家庭。我不得不说耶稣最让我不安的是他的家庭价值观，当你想到外面有这么多团体声称他们的家庭价值观基于圣经时，这太惊人了。我的意思是，他似乎与父母没有真正的紧密联系。他一次又一次残酷地推开玛利亚。在婚礼宴会上，他对她说：女人，这与我有何干？有一次，当他对着人群讲话时，玛利亚耐心地在一旁等待与他交谈。耶稣对门徒说：把她赶走，你们现在是我的家人。
Jesus actually discourages any contact his converts have with their own families. He himself does not marry or have children, and he explicitly tells his followers not to have families as well. And if they do, they should just abandon them. Isn't that what cults do? Get you to reject your family in order to inculcate you?
耶稣实际上阻止了他的皈依者与他们自己的家人联系。他自己没有结婚或生孩子，他也明确告诉追随者不要组建家庭。如果他们有，他们就应该抛弃他们。邪教不就是这么做的吗？让你抛弃你的家人以进行洗脑？
So that's the New Testament family values for you, the supposed big improvement over the Old Testament family values, which seemed to be mostly about incest and mass slaughter and protecting your own specific genetic line at all costs. The Bible. The Good Book. The Good News.
所以这就是送给你的新约家庭价值观，据说是对旧约家庭价值观的重大改进，旧约看起来主要是关于乱伦、集体屠杀和不惜一切代价保护你自己的基因系。圣经。好书。好消息。
I was so disillusioned with the Bible by the time I finished the Epistles, I didn't think it could get any worse. But it did. We were just about to read the last and most oddball book of the Bible, Revelation.
当我读完《书信》时，我对圣经如此失望，我觉得情况不会更糟了。但确实糟了。我们刚要读圣经中最后一本也是最古怪的书，《启示录》。
Revelation tells us that in heaven, Jesus will resemble a dead lamb with seven horns and seven eyes. And when the gates of hell are opened, locusts pour out with human faces wearing tiny crowns, and they sting people with their tails. Revelation tells us that only 144,000 people will even be saved and go to heaven. And none of them will have quote "defiled" themselves with women, which I guess excludes most heterosexual men from heaven. And depending on how you interpret that word "defiled," I would say excludes all women too.
《启示录》告诉我们，在天堂里，耶稣将长得像一只死羊，有七个角和七只眼睛。当通往地狱的大门打开时，长着人脸、戴着小冠冕的蝗虫蜂拥而出，它们用尾巴刺伤人。启示录告诉我们，只有144000人会得救进入天堂。他们中没有人曾因女人而“玷污”自己，我想这把大多数异性恋男性排除在天堂之外了。而且根据你如何解释“玷污”这个词，我会说这也把所有女性都排除了。
As we finished Revelation, the whole Bible study group just sat there, dumbfounded, our Bibles on our laps. I said, Father Tom, I am having a really hard time with this book. And he told me to pray for faith.
当我们读完《启示录》时，整个圣经研习小组只是坐在那里，目瞪口呆，圣经放在我们的膝盖上。我说：汤姆神父，我读这本书真的很吃力。他叫我为信仰祈祷。
I left the church thinking, is this one big practical joke? Where is my God, the Jesus I thought I knew? The one that I love and the one who loves me?
我离开教堂时想：这是一个巨大的恶作剧吗？我的上帝在哪里，那个我以为我认识的耶稣？我爱的那个以及爱我的那个？
I drove home, and I was stopped at this red light on Crenshaw and Wilshire. And I saw all these people walking to church, holding their Bibles. And I wanted to yell out the window, have you read that book?
我开车回家，停在克兰肖（Crenshaw）和威尔希尔（Wilshire）的红绿灯前。我看到所有这些手里拿着圣经去教堂的人。我想从车窗大喊：你们读过那本书吗？
I felt like I was in a horror film. And I realized that the clue to the insanity was not some secret document. It was a book that everyone was holding, that was in every hotel room. The biggest bestseller of all time. And yet if you cared enough to just glance inside, you found you'd opened the door to an insane asylum with a bunch of crazy people dancing around, yelling, "yippidee-yippidee-yah!" And I had quickly shut that door. And how was I going to pretend that I hadn't opened that door?
我感觉自己好像身处一部恐怖片。我意识到疯狂的线索不是什么秘密文件。它是每个人手里拿着的、每个酒店房间里都有的书。有史以来最畅销的书。然而，如果你足够关心并看上一眼，你会发现你打开了一间精神病院的大门，里面有一群疯子在跳舞，大叫着：“耶！”但我迅速关上了那扇门。我怎么能假装我没打开过那扇门呢？
But some things were just too big to ignore. Like the whole point of the New Testament, that Jesus died for our sins. As if someone can pay for someone else's sins.
但有些事情实在太大，无法忽视。就像新约的全部意义：耶稣为我们的罪而死。好像一个人可以为另一个人的罪买单一样。
For the first time, after going to church my whole life, I considered the idea that God's son came to earth and suffered and died for our sins. Why? Jesus suffered, but you can't argue that he suffered any more than a lot of other people have suffered. I could think of examples in my own family. My brother Mike who had cancer, he suffered unspeakably for a very long time. Eyelids freezing open, and his eyes drying up. Canker sores all over his throat, and he couldn't swallow. Weeks and then months of gut-wrenching vomiting and nausea before he then died.
我一生去教堂，第一次考虑这样一个想法：上帝的儿子来到地球，为我们的罪受苦并死去。为什么？耶稣受苦了，但你不能争辩说他比许多其他人受的苦更多。我想到了我自己家庭里的例子。我哥哥迈克（Mike）得了癌症，他在很长一段时间里遭受了无法形容的痛苦。眼皮冻住睁着，眼睛干涸。整个喉咙长满口疮，无法吞咽。在死去之前，经历了数周甚至数月的剧烈呕吐和恶心。
So OK. Jesus suffered. He apparently suffered terribly for one, maybe even two days. I heard someone say once, Jesus had a really bad weekend for our sins.
好吧。耶稣受苦了。他显然为一个，甚至可能是两天，遭受了极其可怕的痛苦。我曾经听人说过，耶稣为我们的罪度过了一个非常糟糕的周末。
I suddenly thought, why would a God create people so imperfect, then blame them for their own imperfections, then send his son to be murdered by those imperfect people to make up for how imperfect those people were? And how imperfect they were inevitably going to be? I mean, what a crazy idea.
我突然想，为什么上帝会创造出如此不完美的人，然后因为他们自己的不完美而责怪他们，然后派遣他的儿子去被那些不完美的人谋杀，来弥补那些人是如何不完美的？以及他们不可避免地将会有多不完美？我的意思是，多么疯狂的想法。
So I tried to concentrate on what I did like about the church. The stained glass windows were pretty. The light in the church. The religious art. The songs. Not the words to the songs exactly, but the melodies were nice. Especially at Christmas. It was also pretty in the church then.
所以我试图专注于我喜欢教会的什么。彩绘玻璃窗很漂亮。教堂里的光。宗教艺术。歌曲。不是歌词，而是旋律很好。特别是在圣诞节。那时教堂里也很美。
After Mass, Father Tom saw me outside the church, and he said, Happy Easter, Julia. And I said, Happy Easter, Father. And he said, you know, I can see you frowning from the pulpit. And I said, I'm sorry, but Father, help me. What can I do? It all just seems impossible to believe.
弥撒后，汤姆神父在教堂外看到我，他说：复活节快乐，朱莉娅。我说：复活节快乐，神父。他说：你知道，我在讲坛上能看到你在皱眉头。我说：对不起，神父，帮帮我。我该怎么办？这一切看起来根本不可信。
He pulled me towards the coffee and doughnuts table. He said, I've spoken with some of the other priests about your predicament. I loved how he said "predicament." I felt like I was 16 and knocked up. I said, yeah? What do they suggest? And he said, listen. We all struggle with doubt, but we all come back. Just remember Proverbs 3:5. Trust in the Lord with all your heart, and lean not on your own understanding.
他把我拉向放咖啡和甜甜圈的桌子。他说，我和其他几位神父谈过你的“困境”。我喜欢他说“困境”这个词。我觉得自己好像16岁未婚先孕。我说：是吗？他们建议什么？他说，听着。我们都与怀疑作斗争，但我们都回来了。只要记住《箴言》3:5。你要专心仰赖耶和华，不可倚靠自己的聪明。
So God gave us the gifts of reasoning and intelligence and curiosity, but then we're not supposed to use them?
所以上帝给了我们理性、智慧和好奇心的天赋，但我们却不能使用它们？
Father Tom sighed, like he was so tired of me and my struggle. And I felt so angry that he used that particular proverb, like he was shutting the door.
汤姆神父叹了口气，好像他厌倦了我以及我的挣扎。我觉得很生气，他用了那句谚语，好像他在关门一样。
Then Father Tom suddenly blessed me. It was kind of awkward. He just started waving his hands over me and chanting this phrase in Latin. Not that this is so out of the ordinary or wrong. It just felt like he was trying to perform an exorcism.
然后汤姆神父突然为我祝福。这有点尴尬。他开始在空中挥手，用拉丁语吟唱这句短语。并不是说这有什么特别反常或错误的。只是感觉他试图在驱魔。
I came home, and it felt remarkably quiet. Just me and God. Not saying much. And the truth was, I was starting to get nervous about our relationship. I felt like we were this married couple in trouble, just trying to find some common ground.
我回到家，感觉异常安静。只有我和上帝。没说太多话。事实是，我开始对我们的关系感到紧张。我觉得我们像一对陷入困境的已婚夫妇，试图寻找一些共同点。
And then one day I was Cometing out my bathtub, and I thought, what if it's true? What if humans are here because of pure, random chance? What if there is no guiding hand, no one watching? I realized I had spent so much time thinking about what God meant that I hadn't really spent any time thinking about what not God meant.
有一天，我正在用清洁剂清洗浴缸，我想，如果是真的呢？如果人类出现在这里是因为纯粹、随机的偶然呢？如果没有指导的手，没有人在看呢？我意识到我花了很多时间思考上帝意味着什么，却没花任何时间思考“不是上帝”意味着什么。
A few days later, as I was walking across my backyard into my house, I realized that there was this teeny-weeny thought whispering inside my head. I'm not sure how long it had been there, but it suddenly got just one decibel louder. And it whispered, there is no God.
几天后，当我穿过后院走进房子时，我意识到脑海中有一个细小的声音在低语。我不确定它在那里多久了，但它突然大了一个分贝。它低语着：没有上帝。
And I tried to ignore it. But it got a teeny bit louder. There is no God. There is no God.
我试着忽略它。但它又大了一点点。没有上帝。没有上帝。
I'm embarrassed to report that I initially felt dizzy. I actually had the thought, well, how does the earth stay up in the sky? You mean we're just hurtling through space? That's so vulnerable. And then I thought, well, what's going to stop me from just rushing out and murdering people?
我很尴尬地报告说，我起初感到头晕。我实际上有这样一个想法：好吧，地球是怎么挂在天空中的？你的意思是说我们只是在太空中横冲直撞？这太脆弱了。然后我想，好吧，什么能阻止我冲出去杀人呢？
And I had to walk myself through it. Like, why are we ethical? Well, we have to get along with each other in order for communities to exist. So I guess that's why I don't run out and just murder people.
我不得不一步步想通它。比如，为什么我们有道德？嗯，为了使社区存在，我们必须相处融洽。所以我猜这就是我为什么不跑出去杀人的原因。
And then I felt like I'd cheated on God somehow. And I went in the house, and I prayed. And I asked God to please help me have faith. But already it felt slightly silly and vacant, and I felt like I was just talking to myself.
然后我感觉自己以某种方式欺骗了上帝。我走进屋子，祈祷。我祈求上帝帮助我拥有信仰。但它已经感觉有点愚蠢和空洞了，我感觉自己只是在自言自语。
And then, over the course of several weeks, God disappeared.
然后，在几周的时间里，上帝消失了。
And I wandered around in a daze, thinking, no one is minding the store. I had shared my mind with God my whole life, and now I realized my thoughts were completely my own. No one was monitoring them. No one was compassionately listening to them.
我恍惚地走来走去，心想：没有人管这个店。我一生都和上帝分享我的思想，现在我意识到我的思想完全是我自己的。没有人监控它们。没有人充满同情地倾听它们。
One day I was sipping my coffee, walking along a busy shopping area near my house. And I was lost in thought, thinking, so I don't think anything happens to us after we die. Our brain just stops like every other organ. So people just die.
有一天，我喝着咖啡，走在离我家很近的一个繁忙购物区。我陷入了沉思：所以我认为我们死后什么也不会发生。我们的大脑就像其他器官一样停止了。所以人们只是死了。
And then I thought, wait a minute. So Hitler, Hitler just died? No one sat him down and said, you screwed up, buddy, and now you're going to spend an eternity in hell. Huh. So Hitler just died.
然后我想：等等。所以希特勒，希特勒只是死了？没有人坐下来对他讲，嘿，你搞砸了，伙计，现在你要在地狱里度过永恒。嗯。所以希特勒只是死了。
And my brother Mike. He just died. I always had this idea that Mike's death, while premature, was his divine destiny somehow. And that his spirit didn't really die, but it lived on. Not just in the memory of those that knew him, but in this real, tangible sense. And I realized that I now thought he died. He really died, and he was gone forever
还有我哥哥迈克。他只是死了。我一直认为迈克的死，虽然早逝，但不知何故是他的神圣命运。他的精神并没有真正死去，而是继续活着。不仅仅是在那些认识他的人的记忆中，而是在这种真实、有形的感觉中。我意识到我现在认为他死了。他真的死了，永远消失了。
And then I realized I had to go back and basically kill off everyone I ever knew who died who I didn't think really died. And then I thought, oh, so I'm going to die.
然后我意识到我不得不回头，基本上杀死了我认识的每一个死去的人，而那些我以为没真正死去的人。然后我想，噢，所以我要死了。
Then I started thinking about all the happenstances, all the random little moves which resulted in me being alive, me, in particular, at this moment. Not just of my parents meeting, but even of the billions of sperm against the hundreds of possible eggs. I thought about this randomness multiplying. My parents, their parents, and all the ways it could have gone one way, but it went the way it went. Richard Dawkins wrote, "Certainly those unborn ghosts include poets greater than Keats, scientists greater than Newton. But in the teeth of these stupefying odds, it is you and I in our ordinariness that are here."
然后我开始思考所有的偶然，所有的随机的小举动，导致了此时此刻活着的我，特别是现在的我。不仅仅是我父母的相遇，甚至包括数以百计的可能卵子与数以亿计的精子的竞争。我想到了这种随机性的倍增。我的父母，他们的父母，以及所有可能走向这一条路但却走向了那一条路的方式。理查德·道金斯写道：“当然，那些未出生的幽灵中包括比济慈更伟大的诗人，比牛顿更伟大的科学家。但在这些令人瞠目结舌的几率面前，是我们这些平凡的你我在这里。”
An excerpt from "Letting Go of God," Julia Sweeney's new one-woman show. She's planning on a movie and a book. For news of all that, go to her website, juliasweeney.com.
这是朱莉娅·斯威尼新单人秀《放下上帝》的摘录。她正在计划拍摄电影并出版书籍。获取相关新闻，请访问她的网站，juliasweeney.com。
Our program is produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Laura Bellows.
我们的节目今天由莎拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、黛安·库克（Diane Cook）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）和莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）参与。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）负责管理我们的网站。托德·巴克曼（Todd Bachmann）和劳拉·贝洛斯（Laura Bellows）提供了制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
You know you can download today's program at our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
你知道你可以在我们的档案库 audible.com/thisamericanlife 下载今天的节目。《美国生活》由公共广播国际台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Torey Malatia, who keeps telling me to give up on these big, conceptual shows about current events that I want to do.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责，他一直告诉我放弃我想做的关于时事的宏大概念性节目。
It's not working. Even your staff doesn't understand them.
根本行不通。连你的员工都不懂它们。
Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
下周回来，收听更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际台。